yes well yeah welcome to the first of
this series of lectures about the
connections between logic and quantum
information quantum information and
computation quantum mechanics I can
repeat what I've said at the beginning
of his lecture there are people here who
know more about the things I'll be
talking about that I do others who will
be very unfamiliar perhaps with things
so I'm mainly aiming to cater for the
latter group because the point of these
lectures is to hopefully cross-fertilize
our discussions in the coming months I
think there are a lot of things coming
out of the work in connecting up
computer science and quantum mechanics
quantum information which can be of
interest to this community and I have to
bring some of those out in these talks
please do ask questions as we go and
also and I'm very glad for any feedback
like if I'm going too fast too slow and
whatever ok so let me begin by hopping
back to my very beginning my time
reserved graduates as a graduate student
PhD student in computer science and I
could actually hear an axiom of computer
science quite early on from my - my
advisor which is that computers might as
well be made of green cheese so you know
the moon is notionally fancifully made
of green cheese the point is it doesn't
really matter what computers are made of
our concerns thinking about software
thinking about logic of computation are
quite independent of all of that
incidentally my adviser was Richard born
at who's been very involved in the
separation logic activity in recent
years which has come to
considerable prominence recently so yeah
so computers might be made of green it
might as well be made of green cheese we
can ignore the physical realization of
computers and just treat them as logical
abstractions and that seemed a very
reasonable position to take for a long
time and that level of abstraction was
very very useful in many ways it's
interesting that Turing in his seminal
paper on computable numbers the sort of
talk about the the sort of physical some
of the physical assumptions underlying
his model of computation as part of this
very detailed and vivid conceptual
discussion of why it's a reasonable
model of computation that made it so
compelling and important Fineman perhaps
unfairly remarked that much later on in
his lectures on on quantum computation
that Turing's analysis of how computers
work working with sort of these squares
of pencil and paper was impeccable
except that he thought that he
understood pencil and paper sort of
meaning that he was implicitly assuming
a classical underlying model for this
sort of representation of information
and the point is that it's no longer
safe to assume this and actually some
very interesting things come out if we
indeed no longer assume it so there's
now an area of I mean it's an
interdisciplinary area and computer
science very actively involved in it and
it's arising from this point that
information processing systems are
obviously physically embodied and the
underlying physics is ultimately quantum
mechanical and taking this seriously
forces us to re-examine many of our
basic assumptions about computer science
and a very interesting work and it's led
to some exciting developments I guess
everyone's heard about these things some
remarkable new algorithms cryptographic
schemes and basic questions in
complexity but I think it also offers
many challenges and opportunities across
the range of computer science and
actually very relevant
to work in the sort of logic in computer
science area so I really seen as a very
exciting and fertile interaction between
computer science and physics involving
other disciplines as well and which is
going to be a big feature of ongoing
science and technology and we can
certainly say from the experience in our
group that it's also attractive to a lot
of students with it with a variety of
different backgrounds ok so the sort of
broad theme of what I'll be talking
about since I can't cover the whole
thing and since I want to emphasize
things that I'd first me that I do know
about and secondly that I think can be
relevant to this program is is the broad
area of nonlocality and contextual 'ti
which also of course involves
entanglement so these are phenomena
which are at the heart of quantum non
classic ality so these are the things
we're going to find out about and come
to find general ways of recognizing
these concepts play a central role in
fact in this rapidly developing field of
quantum information notably in
delineating how quantum resources can
transcend the bounds of classical
information processing and we'll take a
very sort of a small look at this at
right at the end of this lecture just to
get a first feel for that and they also
have in fact profound physical
consequences for our very understanding
of the nature of the world around us at
a fundamental level so the the kind of
experiments that I'll be mentioning
briefly in this lecture have been
described as experimental philosophy or
experimental metaphysics by some of the
people who've been involved in them
because of this way in which the
information that they give us lead to
conclusions which if we don't find
remarkable and hard to understand we've
we sort of haven't have not the point of
them so these two things go go
hand-in-hand in fact and what I'm going
to do is look at a range of ideas and
recent work in which tools that we can
recognize
from from computer science can be used
to shed new light on these phenomena and
actually once we do that we can see that
actually some of these phenomena are not
so unfamiliar also from the perspective
of classical computer science and there
are areas such as relational databases
constraint satisfaction Bayesian
inference and so on we're similar
similar structures have been have come
up so we'll also try and convey
something of that okay but I'd like to
start with something sort of sense of
the what's going on in the world outside
of the exciting recent developments so
actually just last year 2015 was a big
year and actually the last few months of
it was a big year for a famous topic the
idea of Bell's Theorem ringing the bell
is a pun obviously on on that so how
many by the way how I mean obviously
some of you are a sort of experts in the
field because generally how many people
would be able to say what Bell's Theorem
says a few hands but not many and how
many people then would be able to prove
Bell's Theorem well obviously a subset
of the so yeah so anyway by the end of
this lecture you should you should you
should know you should have a good idea
of what it's saying what's interesting
is that Bell's Theorem goes back to a
paper from 1964 and there's been a
half-century of development where people
have gone from the the theoretical
result lots of philosophical discussions
about its consequences I'll show a
timeline shortly but the serious
experiments started in the early 1980s
with Alan a spur and his group in Paris
and just last year three groups of which
this is the first a group based in Delft
published papers are what are widely
accepted now to be the first loophole
free Bell tests demonstrations that what
Bell's Theorem is telling
about reality really is what nature's
telling us and which are free of the
kind of subtle loopholes and possible
objections that that have that have been
a sort of practical difficulty with with
sort of conducting these experiments in
the conclusive fashion so most of the
people in the field or virtually all the
people in the field are surprised by
these results but technologically
they're extremely impressive and the
slogan of the Delft group and Ronald
Hanson in particular is that these bail
tests are a step on the way to the
quantum Internet and they have and the
the nist group which is one of the other
three groups that published experiments
see exactly the technology they've
developed for this loophole free bail
test as giving a source of genuine
certified randomness for example so
there are there are also many
applications to things like device
independent quantum cryptography and so
on so so this is a paper in
paper in I should probably switch my
Wi-Fi off is it going to come back if I
don't switch it off alright
so that this is a sort of more informal
discussion in nature news from last year
of of what this is doing so I don't know
if how many people recognized the person
in this picture but fairly obviously
from the context this is John Bell who
published this paper in 1964 and died in
1990 and actually the expression on the
blackboard is pretty much what's being
used directly in the in these
experiments so and as it says it has a
lot of more immediate applications and
here is a piece by Alan a spare who was
the original pioneer of doing these kind
of experiments who says that by closing
two two of these significant new polls
at once the selection loophole and the
or detection new poll router and the
separation loophole getting the the to
the Alice and Bob far enough apart and
having good enough overcoming the
difficulties with detection inefficiency
is these experimental tests removed the
last down doubts that we should renounce
local realism as he says in other words
essentially the the naive view of
physical reality underlying classical
physics so no small thing and they also
opened the door to new quantum
information technologies so a little
timeline maybe may be useful just to get
a sense of the historical sweep of these
ideas which actually occupy a fairly a
somewhat similar timeline to those of
our own subject in in some ways and
annoyance there in beginning of this as
as he is indeed in computation so the
essentially the the mathematical
formulation of quantum mechanics which
you won't which we'll see a little bit
of in
in these lectures but not not a lot
because we won't need much of it but
nevertheless a very clear formulation of
ordinary quantum mechanics using tools
from functional analysis which for the
purposes of quantum information mainly
reduced to linear algebra was laid down
in his in his classic book translated
into English in 1932 the the paper the
thought experiment that that first
brought to light the idea of
entanglement was the the famous
einstein-podolsky-rosen paradox from
1935 there was this great debate by
Einstein and Bohr so we noticed that
closing the door on Einstein and Bohr's
quantum debate so it took a long time to
close the door maybe it's not quite
closed yet for some a few diehards but
that's what's happening and you see EPR
paradox and will encounter several other
classic results in the field which have
had the name of paradoxes which is
certainly should be interesting for
logicians because these things take us
close to paradox as I like to say they
take us to the borders of paradox in a
rather subtle way without fortunately
taking us right across those borders but
anyway the EPR paradox will we'll see
how that will see other paradoxes then
along along sort of period where these
things lay dormant
the dominant mood was shut up and
calculate and discussions of
foundational topics were were frowned
upon but then Bell not doing his day job
because his day job was working in in
particle physics but following his sort
of own interest published some
absolutely seminal papers which in
particular the one on what we now call
Bell's Theorem from 1964 was crucial and
really that paper is the real found real
starting point of the modern study of
quantum information
like you and the techniques that came to
light from it Bell inequalities and so
on are absolutely central to a great
deal of the current work then the first
experimental tests subject to some of
these objections because of loopholes by
Alan asper and his students you see just
a couple of years afterwards the the
Bennett Prasad a BB 84 quantum key
distribution protocol the beginning of
quantum cryptography just one year later
David Deutsch his paper on quantum
computing which gave rise to the sort of
well the quantum computing idea there
have been earlier discussions by Fineman
and man in but this was the seminal
paper that got things going quantum
teleportation in 1993 teleportation has
now been demonstrated at considerable
distances across the Great Wall of China
and among other places Shor's algorithm
in 94 and then these three loophole free
Bell tests by groups at Delphinus in
Vienna just at the end of last year so
what is underlying this well really this
what we'll focus on in today's lecture
is nonlocality but the broader topic
which we see nonlocality as part is
contextual 'ti so let me say a little
bit about this in general of them we'll
come back to Bell's Theorem in
particular so that by the end of the
lecture we'll have seen at least a first
idea of what else they're a mistaking
and what some of its consequences are so
the the spirit of which we'll be looking
at this is that contextuality which is
another another of these sort of big
ideas about what is non classical about
quantum mechanics it's getting a lot of
interest at the moment because it's seen
as maybe I having been identified as the
key resource that is being used in
giving quantum information processing
and advantage over classical information
and we'll look at some ways of
quantifying that idea later on in these
lectures so a recent paper in Nature for
example has the title contexture
allottee supplies the magic in quantum
computation which is actually a sort of
pump but gives the spirit of what these
ideas are so one of the points that's
emerged in in recent work by a number of
people in the in the community is to
give a more general perspective and the
kind of structural theory of what
contextuality is and part of this is
disentangling it from the specifics of
quantum mechanics and as it were all of
this lends it I think much more
pleasantly to a sort of logical analysis
after all if you want to say that
quantum mechanics is contextual we
should know what contextual 'ti means
without presupposing quantum mechanics
and that's something that we can do so
really it is a general phenomenon and in
fact it appears pervasively in many
fields in logic in computer science and
on locality as exemplified by Bell's
Theorem is a special case of it and
there's a general structure and
mathematical theory that we can apply
across these fields and in a sense we
can take look at many subjects in a
contextual spirit
ok so I've said contextual numerous
times on this slide I don't know what it
means to you in general but what is the
what is the what is the concept here
that we're talking about and of course
the the idea is it underlies these
things which are paradoxes or quasi
paradoxes which are non classical in
some sense so what is it as a kind of
non classical phenomena the best way I
can put it in a nutshell is the
contextual T in this sense arises where
we have a family of data which is
locally consistent but globally
inconsistent and when we put it in those
terms it's not at all unreasonable that
should apply in many situations actually
the idea of local consistency the
terminology of local consistency and
global inconsistency has been used in
the constraint satisfaction
literature and actually appears in
various mathematical context as well but
here we have in a general form something
that relates directly to these
fundamental issues in physics so we'll
come back to more precise formal takes
on this later but let me just give an
initial intuition for what we might mean
so here we can see something as a family
of data showing local consistency a
family of snapshots of some building
some pictures we take with limited
apertures we can't see the whole
building in one go and we can see
various parts of this structure and we
can see that these parts are even
locally consistent because they join
together in a consistent fashion
they join together in a consistent
fashion so this is a locally consistent
family of data
there's nothing problematic about the
this is a as a regular structure
occurring in physical space but now what
happens when we try and put all of this
local data together and get one global
description because after all presumably
there's an actual building out there of
which all these things are snapshots so
then what we get is what you may
recognize as this Escher picture of the
ever ascending staircase and this now is
globally inconsistent if we think about
realizing it as a physical structure in
3-space there of course a whole genre of
visual paradoxes in psychology which
have been which exhibits similar
phenomena there's a sort of local
consistency but global inconsistency
Roger Penrose the mathematician and
mathematical physicist actually
suggested this figure to usher had
correspondence with him and has a strong
interest in these kind of visual
paradoxes and actually the mathematical
treatment he's developed in relation to
them is somewhat of the same flavor as
what we've been studying in in quantum
contextual tea
okay so the borders are paradox well I
mean this is just some kind of you know
visual illusion so you can fool the
brain and so forth so we don't take it
as disturbing on a fundamental level or
they said it's a bit shocking that we
could be fooled that easily but if we
suppose that this phenomenon arises with
observable data so this family of data
is what we can really observe at a
fundamental level which gives us the
best best picture that we have of what
physical reality is actually like and we
make these observations we really
believe them I mean we invest billions
in our particle accelerators and so
forth or in these fancy setups for those
bail tests and we make these local
observations and that they look fine
locally but when we try and fit them
together we have this problem so what
are we meant to make of that well as I
say the reason I speak of the borders of
paradox is because of course it's not
that we observe the data and the data
itself is directly inconsistent I mean
if it was then I don't know we'd have to
give up on logic or something we could
all go home but but in fact the reason
what saves us from a direct conflict
between logic and experience is that the
data cannot be observed globally we
can't observe all the data at the same
time we can't if you like observe all
the variables at the same time we can
only observe certain subsets of
variables the subs each subset that we
can observe directly each empirical
window that we can make on reality is
internally consistent so that's okay
it's when we try and piece it together
that we encounter a problem and what
this is telling us is that the only way
we can save the appearances and prevent
a direct contradiction is to say that
really we can't in any theory that's
going to extend into what we want to
know now and be able to to directly
observe all the measurable variables at
the same time the fact that model that
you get non commuting observables is a
feature
quantum mechanics a famous feature of
quantum mechanics but actually because
of this connection with consistency it's
it's a it's a necessary feature of any
physical theory that extends quantum
mechanics so that's already quite a
disturbing thing of course we'll we'll
come back to that but this should give a
first flavor of what's going on now
let's go from the general discussion to
something much more concrete which is
going to take us in fact two Bell's
Theorem fairly directly so let's
consider the following scenario and at
this point I'm not talking physics and
quantum mechanics let's just think of a
couple of agents in a network Alice and
Bob and the way I'll set that set this
up in such a way that Alice is sitting
somewhere on a network it has a couple
of a couple of local a couple of local
registers bit registers and what Alice
can do is is select one of these to load
into her processing unit then observe
its value which could then be
transmitted to some target so she might
decide for example to load a to observe
it contains the value one and send this
on to a common target a Bob similarly
has local bit registers confused to load
one observe its contents so he could he
could he could for example load b1 and
observe that it contained zero so that's
clear and now we think that they don't
just do this once but they do multiple
rounds of this process and on different
rounds they may find different values in
the variables there may be some agency
that is causing the values of the bit
registers to change so what they can do
is record statistics of what they see
they can get frequencies and from the
frequencies observe statistics so for
example they might end up with the
following table now what is this table
say well we have Alice and Bob whoops we
have Alice and Bob so Alice could choose
to load one of
one of her registers Bob could choose to
lose one of his registers for each
combination for example over here what
this entry is saying that on those
occasions when Alice looks at a1 and Bob
looks at B 2 then 1/8 of the time Alice
sees a0 and Bob sees r1 okay so you see
across each row conditioned on which
registers Alice and Bob looked at we get
a probability distribution of the
possible outcomes this is everyone clear
about this what this table is saying ok
so this is a table of 16 numbers what is
it telling us what is it saying to us
how can we make it speak to us firstly
should we be disturbed by it or is it a
perfectly fine table well this is the
kind of question we have to ask so a
natural question is by what mechanism
can we explain this behavior so let me
give what I think is the a
straightforward way of explaining this
behavior would be a straightforward way
of explaining this behavior which is to
postulate a mechanism in the background
which we can call a classical source so
it's some process which on each round
chooses values for all the variables not
knowing which ones Alice and Bob are
going to select and simply writes those
values into those registers so for
example if I'm a given round it writes
these values into these registers then
indeed if Alice looks at a2 she'll find
the one that this source put there and
if Bob looks at b1 it'll find the zero
that this source put there and and this
process implies on generating these
values and we can imagine this in
software we have probabilities here that
this source itself doesn't have to work
in a deterministic fashion
it could be sampling these 16 very
possible values it could write into the
four registers from some probability
distribution this would be a kind of
shared randomness between Alice and Bob
which would which could explain the
experiences and the question is is there
any such classical source that can
explain this possible this description
of experience by Alice and Bob would
there be any such mechanism so let's
answer the question by stepping back a
little and answering a more general
question which will be enlightening and
this is a very embarrassing ly simple
piece of formal derivation - it may be
in the probability 101 early arm but
nevertheless it will be extremely useful
so suppose we have some I call that say
propositional formulas in other words
describing events so the idea is that
these formulas are in variables the
variables can take the values 0 or 1 and
if we think of measuring variables that
can have the value 0 or 1 each formula
describes an event and if you think
about these variables as being things we
can empirically measure and get
statistics just in the way we were
saying over here and it's reasonable
that or here and it's reasonable that we
can assign probability is based on that
to these events but we're not making any
other assumptions here so we have a
bunch of formulas they describe events
over 0 1 value variables and we assign
probabilities to these events and I'm
going to make one assumption very
typical assumption although it's not
often made explicit in the in the
physics literature but which is
certainly worthy of attention from
logicians which is we're gonna make one
assumption that the formulas are not
simultaneously satisfiable some kind of
logical constraint going on and of
course what this says is if you take the
conjunction of any n - one of them they
must imply the negation of the end or
contra positively if the enth is true
one of the others must be false so we
all
agree with that now we switch from logic
101 to probability 1 I want to make the
following derivation that just from
monotonicity here the probability of
this event must be less than or equal to
the probability of this event and then
just using subadditivity of probability
of bulls law as it's sometimes known we
just get that it's less than the sum of
these probabilities and this is a very
crude formula of course but it's
certainly true in standard probability
and even much weaker things and then we
just expand the formula for the
complement of an event and collect terms
and what we get is that the sum of these
probabilities under this assumption must
be bounded by n minus 1 does everyone
happy with that
very simple derivation yep ok don't
complain later if you don't like the
consequences ok so we've we've we've
derived so now's your chance so so we
derive this and now what can we do with
it well let's come back to that bail
table and answer our question the
question was could we explain that
experience of hypothetical experience of
Alice and Bob by a classical source so
how do we apply our little derivation to
the situation of bells of the bell table
well what I do is on each row I define
an event which can obviously be
described by a formula so notice on the
first three rows I'm taking the
correlated events 0 0 1 1 which the
thinking of these as propositional
variables are described by the if and
only if formulas those are the Centers
of the satisfying assignments for these
formulas and on the fourth row I take
the anti-correlated event 1 0 0 1 which
is just described by the exclusive-or of
those formulas
okay so those are four simple formulas
now it's easy to see that these formulas
are not simultaneously satisfiable for
example if we start here we can replace
a 2 by B 1 we can replace B 1 by a 1 we
can replace a 1 by B 2 and we've ended
up with B 2 exclusive or B 2 which is
obviously not satisfiable we'll see a
much more beautiful way of seeing this I
means very simple but a beautiful way
that generalizes topologically in the
next lecture but anyway we can see that
these formulas are not simultaneously
satisfiable now we take that simple
piece of reasoning we had here and we
conclude that it must be the case that
the sum of the probabilities of these
events is bounded by 3 ok that's what
the that's what that theorem told us if
we now see we get 1 on the first line
and 6/8 on each of the other line then
we get something that exceeds 3 that
violates it by 1/4 so I must have pulled
a fast one on you somehow but what what
did we do
and not really I mean the derivation was
perfectly good but there is one
important assumption in this derivation
which correlates to the idea of a
classical source so would anyone like to
say what it is and where it happens in
this derivation
well it's not bad to mull on these
things so maybe I'll leave that with you
but anyway that's that's what's happened
really under the assumption of a
classical source we've we we we we would
have got a bound of three and we've
derived a violation of the bound so we
can so we can answer definitively that
for this experience there's no
explanation by a classical source that's
the important point which of course
raises the question well you know maybe
this is just a science fiction
experience but that's what those
experiments are telling us it's not a
science fiction experience it's a
science fact experience we actually get
these violations okay so now let's look
at an even stronger example of the same
thing and this is by the way standardly
known as the Hardy paradox so this is
another one of those places where the
word paradox is used so it should be an
alert to logicians well it's beautiful
about this example is that it makes the
same point without even needing to give
the detailed information of the
probabilities all I need to do here is
to write the support of the model it's
the same kind of model Alice and Bob
outcomes probabilities of outcomes but
instead of writing the actual
probabilities I write only 0 for
probability 0 1 for probability greater
than 0 and just from this information
actually even less than what I've
written down here we can already tell
that there is no explanation by a
classical source so let's see how we can
how we can do this again I'm gonna pick
out to use the same principle that we
derived a couple of slides ago I'm gonna
pick out an event on each row and you
can see that these are described by
these formulas here I'm taking zeros
true and 1 as false
I mean don't really matter but
doing so this one here is described by a
and B in these variables and then you
see we get the descriptions of these
things
okay so we're all happy that these are
these events are described by these
formulas and again we can easily see
that these formulas are not
simultaneously satisfiable so the first
and the second we get not B Prime the
first and the third we get not a prime
and from our a prime or not B prime we
get a contradiction with a prime or B
prime so they're not simultaneously
satisfiable now I don't have the actual
probabilities but nevertheless I know
that that inequality we derived earlier
must be violated how do I know that well
what's that what must the probability of
this event be bearing in mind that this
is a normalized probability distribution
what because the whole support is there
similarly here and similarly here so
these three rows give me three and
whatever this is it's positive so
therefore we get something greater than
three and the inequality has been
violated so even without writing the
probabilities down we know that that we
have a violation of that inequality so
so this is the Hardy paradox and we'll
encounter it again later in various and
forms yes
which parts of these are the local
consistencies their rolls very good well
I mean to the globe the global
inconsistency here is reflected by the
fact that these these four events are
not simultaneously satisfiable the the
local inconsistency which will obviously
kind of capture formally in a little
while and actually the next lecture I
think where I have it at the moment but
we can we can say more about it now
local consistency is going to be that if
you look at two of the rows and you look
at the marginals for a variable they
have in common that they're consistent
you get the same marginal so for example
if a we can't see this we don't have
numbers here but let's come back here so
for example here you see the first two
rows have the variable a1 in common now
if you marginalize the the probability
of getting of getting outcome 0 for a1
from just from this row you see you get
the probability of getting zero you see
you get 1/2 plus 0 so the marginal
probability is 1/2 and if you
marginalize on this row then you get 3/8
plus 1/8 so they're the same and that
turns out to be a very important
physically motivated principle once
those are no signaling principle which
is guaranteeing consistency with with
relativity so so that's the sense of
local consistency pairwise looking at
these distributions there are no obvious
clashes between them they fit together
but there's no way of gluing them all
together into a single joint
distribution in this example of the rows
and columns all add up to 1 and in the
other ones
a monk difference you're saying the
columns add up to one I mean anyway so I
don't think they do but anyway it's the
rows the rows of probability
distributions so the idea is you have a
family of probability distributions
indexed by the context which are the
rows so you can think of them as
conditioned on the choices of the of
which things we measure and the point is
that remember those aren't those aren't
those aren't probabilities those are
merely indicating the support so
actually it's possible to write in
numbers which would give us probability
distributions and which would give us
this support and not only that but
numbers that again we have every reason
to consider are real things that we
could see by experiment right so yeah so
it's important to distinguish between
this case where we're looking at the
support one of the interesting things
that's come to light in the things we've
been looking at which i think is sort of
mediates this in these interesting
connections with logic is a lot of the
structure of the obviously some of the
information important information is
conveyed in the probabilities but a lot
of it is of the structural information
is already apparent at the level of the
support where we really are just dealing
with with logic and in particular the
way we derived the bell inequality only
used a consistency assumption on the
underlying events I mean we were saying
because you know the the k.k events they
weren't consistent then then a bound on
the probabilities had to necessarily be
K minus 1 and there's a sort of more
general version of that and that more
general version actually gives us a
general take on Berlin equality so by
the way that inequality that we've been
using this thing over here is is an
example of a Berlin in quantity and
actually with us you
generalization as I was saying all to to
sort of not just to looking about the
maximal consistent subset say see here I
said that the whole set of formulas was
not simultaneously satisfiable and I got
this bound here if I'd have said at most
K of those formulas are simultaneously
satisfied well I could have got a
sharper bound here of K and if I use
that more general principle that would
actually be a completely general way of
deriving Bell inequalities right so so
we have already by the way essentially
proved a version of Bell's Theorem let's
just say a bit more about that and it'll
be time to wrap up so let's come back to
the question of what do observables
observe I mean this idea that how you
know that this we should in some sense
find this a bit shocking because we can
think of these things as really
measuring basic physical quantities so
what we would think is that observables
observe a classically things like
position and momentum current and other
such things measure objective properties
of a physical system which are
independent of our choice of which
measurements to perform of our
measurement context and what this is
saying is that for each possible state
of the system there's some function
which for each measurement you could do
whether you do it or not specifies an
outcome independently of which other
measurements might be performed well
that certainly the point of view taken
in classical physics I mean every
particle has a well-defined position and
momentum and whether whether I measure
it or not whether I'm measuring some
other particle or not it shouldn't make
a difference so this point of view which
we might just think of as common sense
it's called non contextual T and in this
setting it's equivalent to the
assumption of a classical source and
this view because the classical source
is really saying there's a global
description of even if there's some
randomness in the system it's sort of at
the level of all the variables at the
same
time but it's this view which is
impossible to sustain in the light of
our actual observations so here is the
same picture we had before with Alice
and Bob but now dressed up more the way
that it would traditionally be
represented in physics so here's Alice
and Bob we now think not of these local
bit registers but of choices they make
of which measurement to perform so it
might be measuring a choice of direction
in which to measure spin of some
particle or it might be photon
polarization or something else and on
the other hand we think this classical
source is is traditionally would be
called a local hidden variable actually
in there are there's beautiful
presentations of the classic
presentations of these going back to the
early 90s by David Merman a physicist
and he used the term instruction sets
for these assignments so that's which is
I think intentionally a computer science
terms but you see this way of portraying
it although we use a slightly different
terminology structurally as isomorphic
to the description we had before it's
the same thing now what we might think
is that okay I write I put this table
down maybe that's just a piece of
science fiction but if we use quantum
rather than classical resources it is
realisable and more specifically if we
use an entangled qubit as a shared
resource between Alice and Bob rather
than this kind of shared district
classical distribution then behavior of
exactly the kind we've considered can be
achieved and actually what those
experiments are here to show us is that
is that exactly this can be seen this
kind of behavior can be seen in these
violations of Berlin equalities and
we'll actually see in a later lecture I
mean we're going to go very far into
developing a lot of quantum mechanical
formalism but it's actually pretty
simple to go far enough to see how to
actually
calculate such a table directly from the
predictions of quantum mechanics the
born rule they use is nothing more than
a little than your algebra so we'll see
that okay so in the quantum case I mean
just to just to say a little bit about
that now so how do things look well the
basic states of a system that as is used
in quantum information so called
two-level systems the analog of the bit
I'll describe or the pure states are
described by complex unit vectors
two-dimensional unit vectors those of
you went to Andreas's talk the other day
we'll have had a very nice overview of
this so because they're normalized
because they're unit vectors they could
be have a nice representation as points
on the unit sphere and so you see
there's a continuum of places on the
sphere where that where where these
where these states can be subside can be
anywhere on the sphere and also we can
measure spin in any direction in space
so spin is well it's been spinning as a
fundamental physical thing I mean first
observed famous experiments from 1920s
it's an inherent property at the quantum
mechanical level of nature having you
sort of put these atoms through a
magnetic beam and they get dispersed I
mean you can you can think of them as
little spinning tops and they're getting
deflected but then if they were
classical spinning tops they could get
deflected anywhere and a continuum of
positions and here we see one of the
beautiful
ways that quantization emerges what is
actually observed modulo the
imperfections of experiment is that they
get they get deflected into just one of
two places being up or spin down in the
given direction and it's this two-valued
nurse this quantization that lets us
make a model of information processing
with these physical systems so we can we
can pick a direction with a
corresponding pair of antipodal points
on the sphere and that gives us a
direction for defining a measurement
meanwhile thus the state of the system
could be any other point on the sphere
so even though there's a continuum of
directions and a continuum of states an
actual measurement has a one of only two
possible outcomes spin up or spin down
in the chosen direction so this is the
BLA sphere representation of qubits and
so those are the those are the sort of
basic
basic setup for a quantum model of
information processing so what we'll see
a bit more about this in a later lecture
let me just mention that things get
really interesting not when we have a
single qubit in isolation where we have
multiple qubits because then the
phenomena of entanglement appear so here
is the bell state we mentioned the EPR
experiment from the 1930s earlier on in
our timeline and they say this is this
kind of simplified version basically due
to bone of what they were discussing
there but I mean if we just take the
bell state as the simplest case so this
is a state we can prepare of two qubits
where one may end up being held by Alice
and one by Bob and what this is saying
is for fixing our direction of measuring
spin this is such that if we measure if
Alice measured in that direction she
might get spin up or she might get spin
down but from the nature of this
superposition of states if she gets spin
up then as we see one says the state
collapses in such a way that now if Bob
were to measure he could only again spin
up and similarly if Alice got spin down
and this is even though Alice and Bob
may be a long long way apart from each
other space like separated and this all
falls out mathematically from the fact
that compound systems are represented
not by some Cartesian product but by the
tensor product of the linear spaces that
the state city and the elements of this
tensor product are given by linear
combinations of these pairings of
pairings of vectors and this kind of
superposition can encode correlation for
example some of these coefficients can
go to zero and then we get a highly
entangled state such as this one and
this is what Einstein famously called
spooky action at a distance even if the
particles are spatially separated
measuring 1 has an effect on the state
of the other actually there's a lot of
philosophical quibbles about this but
operationally this
is this is what happens
and now Bell's Theorem is that quantum
mechanics is essentially non-local in
the sense that we've seen in the sense
that it really predicts exactly this
kind of behavior that we've we would
just been describing this right by the
Bell table for example and which can't
be explained by a by a classical source
so if we come back to this table just to
underline the point this model can is
predicted by quantum mechanics there's
an entangled state of two qubits and
directions for spin measurements which
Alice and Bob can make which generate
this table according to the predictions
of quantum mechanics and moreover it's
exactly this kind of behavior which has
been confirmed by these new poll free
Bell tests so we're going to have to put
up with this as part of our view of view
of reality and and also more to the
point we can seek to exploit it because
it can yield new possibilities for
various information processing tasks so
we'll see a bit later how to actually
calculate this kind of table it is a
straightforward matter but perhaps
useful to fix the ideas okay so let me
just finish up by brie very briefly
giving your first idea of how this kind
of behavior can lead to in some modest
admittedly not immediately very useful
information processing task but
nevertheless an information processing
task playing a simple game in fact and
how it can yield an information an
advantage compared with classical
resources so this is what's known as the
XOR game which is just another again
another isomorphic way of looking at the
same situation that was described by the
bell table and those kind of tables we
were looking at so we can think of this
as a game played against nature by Alice
and Bob and they're sort of trying to
cooperate and coordinate with each other
as is the idea
so the terminology changes slightly from
what we had before because we talked
about inputs and outputs so the idea is
that nature now is choosing an input for
Alice and an input for Bob and choosing
the input 0 for Alice in it which is the
way it's usually written and sort of
it's why
well the by anyway choosing an input 0
for Alice corresponds to choosing the
setting a 1 that we had earlier so sorry
for the small clash in notation but
that's what it is and on the other hand
choosing the input 1 corresponds to
choosing the setting a 2 or the register
a 2 and suddenly an input Y for Bob and
we assume here that that nature's choice
is a uniformly distributed over these
four possibilities of choosing 0 on for
Alice 0 on for Bob these inputs having
been chosen Alice and Bob have to choose
their outputs which are going to be 0
and 1 again and of course their output
can depend on for each of them their
output can depend on their input and the
point about writing it in this notation
is that we can express the winning
condition in this way that the outputs
the exclusive order of the outputs have
to be the same as the conjunction of the
inputs thinking of them all as boolean
variables now if you think about what
that means and we go back to our table
so the the case is the first three rows
correspond to the cases where the inputs
one of at least one of them is zero so
therefore the conjunction is false and
therefore the output has to be X a or B
has to be false as well and those are
exactly the anti-correlated outputs so
that condition for the first three rows
is picking out the correlated outputs in
each case which would remember the
highlighted events we had earlier on in
our derivation of the bell inequality on
the other hand in the fourth row
the conjunction is true it's a 1 in both
1 input in both for both Alice and Bob
and then the the exclusive order of the
outputs has to be true in other words
we're in the anti-correlated case so the
the winning winning conditions for this
game are either than we're correlated in
each of the first three rows or that
we're anti-correlated in the fourth row
and those are exactly the events that we
had earlier and we can think of any
probability table of the kind we've been
looking at as defining a strategy for
this game the strategy says if nature
chooses those inputs that row of the
table here is my probability for
choosing each of the outcomes and the
success probability for the strategy is
exactly got by taking all the by taking
the probabilities of being correlated in
the cases where x and y is false and
anti current in other words a or b being
false as well or together with the
probability of being correlated in the
case where a sorry of being yes of being
anti-correlated meaning a X or B is true
in the case where x and y is true so
those are exactly the same for
probabilities we were looking at in our
derivation of the bell inequality so
that's what the width the success
probability for any given strategy is so
you see it's just another way of looking
at the same structure we were discussing
before so we have a game and we have for
any two such table we have a success
probability which defines a strategy we
have a success probability for that
strategies now we can pick out the idea
of a classical strategy which is one
where Alice and Bob can have shared
initial information shared randomness
for example but cannot communicate with
each other once the game starts and this
is this is what corresponds to the
classical source
and what are now in this interpretation
what our legit logical Bell inequality
is doing is that it's bounding the
maximum success probability of any
classical strategy that's exactly what
it's doing and actually that success
probability can be saturated because we
can find even a deterministic assignment
doesn't even have to be a mixed strategy
deterministic assignment that will make
three of those formulas true so we will
get this classical probability won't
we've normalized by the probabilities of
our manager so we've we've once we
normalized by the the fact that we're we
have a quarter probability of choosing
each of nature choosing each of the rows
and so our three that we had in our
previous bound now becomes the maximum
success probability of 3/4
so we've reinterpreted it's exactly the
same mathematical content but we've
reinterpreted the Bell inequality as
bounding the maximum success probability
for any classical strategy and moreover
this bound can be attained the bill
table exceeds this band and it's quantum
realisable so we've already see from
that a first example of how the use of
quantum resources yield a quantum
advantage in an information processing
task and of course quantum information
is all about such examples of quantum
advantage okay
so I'll stop there
therefore any questions now but happy to
this context I'll say logic can't go
wrong thank you for the actions of
reliability theory I want good question
probability theory well using very mild
assumptions yes indeed we are so one way
of looking at what what comes out of
this is that we're using the tools of
classical probability theory but in a in
a way where we're building in the I mean
the fact that it can vary over context
so actually mathematically the the you
know the this is why she Pheidias coming
very naturally we're varying over
contexts and within each context we have
a classical probability distribution but
is this variation over context at least
a non classical phenomena so actually in
a sense the two are in two are in
harmony but the place where they but
what you can't do is just reduce it to a
single probability space
we said earlier on that we cannot
observe all of the variables at the same
time yeah what's your definition of time
well it's it's it doesn't need a very
delicate if you like it could be in the
same the same run so it's not that there
have to be simultaneous because that I
mean but it but it's the if you think
about it load the constraint locally in
the scenario we were talking about is
that Alice can look at one of her bit
registers but not of both of them at the
same time and that's just you know in
that in that particular set up that was
a very natural constraint and more
generally if you if you know if you
measure spin in one direction you can't
be measuring it in another direction at
the same time because there's a single
physical system you're subjecting to
this process of doing the measurement
and you can't be doing both at the same
time so that's the kind of constraint
that we see the sort of concrete level
and the point is that any physical
theory is going to make these
predictions is going to have to have
constraints of that form it seems to me
because otherwise we would get into a
problem with consistency
well maybe another way to phrase it is
that nature doesn't really answer
hypotheticals so in the classical world
we expect to be to be able to answer
questions like what would have happened
to valleys have looked of your other
nature somehow doesn't answer such
questions consistently right the answers
yes so classically there's every reason
to believe that there is a well-defined
answer to those questions and we could
even hope in principle if we've sort of
developed clever enough technology to
measure everything well then no doubt
there are some limits but but here we
know a prat well pretty much a priority
for this kind of argument that we're
never going to be able to and we have to
regard them as not as ill-posed
questions
right so we have a break